la page cinéma maintenant avec le
festival de cannes bien sûr est le
premier film français en compétition ce
soir il s'agit des chansons d'amour avec
ludivine sagnier et chiara mastroianni
que nous retrouverons en duplex dans
quelques minutes une comédie musicale de
christophe honoré que nous présente
marie logement et nadine picard sur le
tapis rouge le charme le talent
l'insolence de la jeunesse lady linn
sagnet claudine m louis garrel chiara
mastroianni avec les chansons d'amour
premier film français en compétition
christophe honoré a réuni la jeune garde
du cinéma français tu es heureux
d'amener ses comédiens la can je coupais
ils représentent tous une certaine idée
du cinéma français moi j'ai envie de
défendre une vraie jeunesse une audace
et les jardins de jeunes lecteurs et
dans une histoire tournant autour d'un
trio amoureux à la jules et jim qui
vivent dans l'insouciance jusqu'au jour
où une tragédie va les prendre de plein
fouet les listes soient conséquents
fusion pour son quatrième film
christophe honoré a choisi une narration
originale parler d'amour oui mais en
chansons le cinéaste est un fan de
jacques benouw j'avais envie pour la
première fois d'évoquer vraiment à une
histoire d'amour enfin sentiment
amoureux et les chansons voilà je mets
bien cette idée que des personnages
étaient incapables d'exprimer leurs
sentiments autrement qu'en chantant et
que le moment des chansons allaient être
le moment où le délivrer leurs émotions
intime au jeu est claire la chanson ici
et comme une bouffée d'air frais dans un
film émouvant et parfois dramatique deux
pour le prix d'une
à 23 ans louis garrel retrouve pour la
troisième fois christophe honoré la
compétition le vent monsieur est du
signe à la fois il ya des porsche
maserati des ferrari
bon bien que la 4l booster et puis bon
ben il faut faire un cours sont mais
c'est bien parce qu'on fait pas la
course en tête ont fait la course
derrière on va faire la course en tête
avec tarantino que des comédies
musicales et parapluies de cherbourg et
danseurs in the dark avec été primé à
cannes les nombres du jury qui faisait
10 et à ses chansons d'amour